Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
YAYA STRUGGLED
WITH THE JUDGES' FEEDBACK.
Nigel: YOU DON'T WANT
TO ALWAYS LOOK DANCER,
DANCER, DANCER,
DANCER, DANCER.
Yaya: BUT THAT IS
100% ME.
Tyra: RUMORS OF CASSIE'S
EATING DISORDER
RIPPLED
THROUGH THE HOUSE.
Cassie: BUT I DON'T WANNA
TALK ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
AND I DON'T WANT ANYONE ELSE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
Tyra: CONTINUED CRITICISM
BROKE KELLE DOWN.
Kelle: (sobs)
Tyra: BUT AT THE ELIMINATION
KELLE ADVANCED,
AND IT WAS JENNIPHER
WHO WAS SENT HOME.
ONLY NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Kelle: DADDY,
Man: Yeah?
Kelle: I DON'T HAVE INTENSITY
IN MY EYES.
I KEEP TRYING DIFFERENT THINGS
AND THINKING DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND I-I DON'T KNOW.
YESTERDAY
DURING ELIMINATION
I HAD ANOTHER
NOT-SO-FLATTERING PHOTO.
Tyra: KELLE,
YOUR PICTURES HAVE BEEN,
LITERALLY,
SOME OF THE WORST
IN THE BUNCH.
Kelle: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WHAT TO DO.
AND IT'S LIKE,
NO MATTER HOW HARD I TRY,
I STILL
DON'T GET IT.
I JUST NEED HELP.
Tyra: THANKS,
JENNIPHER.
Cassie: JENN
WAS ELIMINATED.
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS HERE,
WE HAD TALKED THE MOST.
I DON'T PARTICULARLY
GET ALONG
WITH THE REST OF THE GIRLS
IN THE HOUSE.
I'M A LONER
AND I'M USED TO IT.
SO I'LL SIT ON MY BED
BY MYSELF,
AND I'LL BE FINE.
Amanda: TRASH, TRASH,
TRASH,
TRASH, TRASH, TRASH.
LOOK
AT THE TRASH.
IT'S LIKE LIVING WITH
EIGHT OTHER BEAUTIFUL PIGS.
TRASH IN THERE
WITHOUT A TRASH BAG,
LEAVING FOOD
ON THE COUNTER,
COME ON.
THIS MORNING PEOPLE
WERE JUST PILING TRASH
AROUND
THE GARBAGE CAN.
Eva: AND WE KNOW
WHO THE PEOPLE ARE.
Amanda: BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH... (blows raspberry)
RIGHT NOW CASSIE IS PRETTY MUCH
THE SLOPPIEST ONE
WITH DIET COKES AND SUCH
STREWN ABOUT THE HOUSE.
SHE'S A SLOPPY SLUT.
Tyra: WAKE UP!
Norelle: I LOVE THAT
TYRA BANKS CAME INTO OUR ROOM
AND JUMPED ON OUR BEDS
TO WAKE US UP.
LIKE, IT MAKES ME HAPPY,
'CAUSE SHE'S LIKE A REAL PERSON.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY,
SO TODAY
I'M GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT THE MODELING INDUSTRY
IN TERMS OF EATING, BODY IMAGE,
AND THE PRESSURES
TO HAVE TO FIT INTO
A CERTAIN MOLD.
I HAVE A FRIEND
OF MINE,
HER NAME
IS KATE DILLON.
KATE AND I USED TO MODEL
IN LOS ANGELES AND IN PARIS.
AND SHE'S ONE OF THE TOP
PLUS-SIZED MODELS
IN THE INDUSTRY.
SO THIS IS
KATE DILLON.
Women: HEY!
Kate: I HAVE BEEN A MODEL
SINCE I WAS, GOSH, 17 YEARS OLD.
AND I WAS THE FIRST PLUS-SIZED
MODEL EVER TO BE IN "VOGUE."
Toccara: I THINK I STARED
AT KATE LIKE THE WHOLE TIME,
LIKE, "WOW,
THAT'S GONNA BE ME."
LIKE, I'M GONNA BE THE FIRST
BLACK PLUS-SIZED GIRL.
Kate: I STARTED OUT
AS A SKINNY MODEL.
IN ORDER TO BE A "SKINNY" MODEL,
UM, YOU HAVE TO BE "SKINNY."
AND FOR ME,
IT WAS REALLY, REALLY DIFFICULT.
I ACTUALLY HAD
AN EATING DISORDER.
I'D GO DAYS
WITHOUT EATING
OR JUST MAYBE EATING,
YOU KNOW, AN APPLE
OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
AND I COULDN'T STAY
IN THE BUSINESS AS I WAS.
I WAS UNHEALTHY.
I WAS
MISERABLE.
AND I ENDED UP QUITTING
THE BUSINESS.
I GAINED, LIKE, 50 POUNDS
AND ENDED UP RETURNING,
BUT AS
A PLUS-SIZED MODEL.
THIS MIGHT NOT BE
THE RIGHT CAREER FOR ANY OF YOU.
IF IT'S NOT THE RIGHT CAREER
FOR YOU,
DON'T TRY TO MANIPULATE YOURSELF
AT ANY COST TO FIT INTO IT.
Tyra: IN A WAY
YOU GUYS ARE ATHLETES,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO WORK
ON YOUR BODY.
YOU HAVE TO STAY IN SHAPE,
AND YOUR CAREERS ARE TEMPORARY.
SO WE'RE GONNA TALK TODAY
ABOUT HOW TO DO THIS HEALTHILY.
AND WE HAVE A WOMAN HERE
THAT IS GOING TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THAT
EVEN FURTHER.
Woman: HEY!
Tyra: COME AND SIT
RIGHT HERE.
Joy: FOR OVER 15 YEARS
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH MODELS,
HELPING THEM TO MANAGE
THEIR WEIGHT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT BALANCING,
MODERATION AND CONSISTENCY.
Nicole: YEAH,
I DO, TOO.
Joy: NOBODY NEEDS
TO BE AFRAID OF CARBOHYDRATE.
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS PREACHING RIGHT NOW,
THESE ARE THE FOODS
THAT YOU NEED TO MODERATE,
BUT NOT ELIMINATE.
Tyra: I WANNA KNOW
IF ANYBODY WANTS TO DO
LIKE A ONE-ON-ONE
WITH THE THREE OF US.
Cassie: WELL, I WANNA DO
A ONE-ON-ONE WITH YOU SOMETIME.
Tyra: SO IF EVERYONE ELSE CAN GO
INTO THE BEDROOMS FOR NOW.
Cassie: YOU KNOW,
IF I WANNA BE A MODEL,
I FEEL LIKE
I SHOULD BE SKINNY.
I WON'T SAY THAT I HAVE
A DISORDER,
BUT I WORRY ABOUT
WHAT I EAT 24/7.
Joy: DO YOU EVER FEEL
THAT IT GETS OUT OF CONTROL
AND THEN YOU DO A WHOLE
GUILT HEAD TRIP ON YOURSELF?
Cassie: MM-HMM,
I HAVE HAD SEVERAL TIMES
WHERE I'VE THROWN UP
IN THE PAST.
BUT I NEVER CONSIDERED MYSELF
BULIMIC,
BECAUSE I DIDN'T
THROW UP AFTER EVERY MEAL,
AND I WOULD JUST DO IT AT NIGHT,
IF I THOUGHT I ATE TOO MUCH,
AND I SHOULDN'T GO TO BED
WITH IT IN MY STOMACH.
Joy: I GET NERVOUS WHEN
I HEAR THAT YOU'VE THROWN UP.
DID YOU EVER TALK TO ANYBODY
ABOUT THAT?
Cassie: MNH-MNH.
Joy: MAYBE WE SHOULD EXPLORE
HAVING YOU TALK TO SOMEBODY,
ONLY BECAUSE IT COULD REALLY
SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL.
Tyra: ESPECIALLY
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
WITH THE PRESSURE
AND THE CRITIQUE.
Cassie: I DON'T FEEL LIKE
I CAN TALK TO SOMEONE
AND THEY WILL KNOW
HOW I FEEL.
YOU CAN TELL ME I SHOULDN'T
DO THAT ALL YOU WANT,
BUT IF I FEEL LIKE I'M STILL
I'M STILL GONNA DO IT,
I'M NEVER
GONNA BE HELPED.
Tyra: I WISH
SHE WOULD'VE...
Kate: (whispers) PEOPLE WITH
EATING DISORDERS ARE HARD-CORE.
Cassie: C.J.
C.J.: What's up?
Cassie: I THINK THEY WANT ME
TO GO TO A COUNSELOR.
C.J.: Why?
Cassie:
FOR YOU KNOW WHAT.
C.J.: They know?
Cassie: MM-HMM.
C.J.: How?
Cassie:
I HAD TO TELL.
IF I'M FEELING THAT I'M HAPPY,
AND I'M DOING FINE,
AND THIS IS MAKING ME HAPPY
BY DOING THIS,
THEN THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS
TO ME.
Cassie: GIRLS,
THERE'S FOOD OUT THERE.
IT'S JUST, LIKE,
FRUIT AND SALAD.
IT'S NOT LIKE A BUNCH
OF MEALS.
Ann: I SMELL CAKE.
Cassie: IT'S BROWNIES.
Ann: CASSIE HAD MADE
BROWNIES.
YOU KNOW,
LOW CARB BROWNIES.
THEY CAN ONLY
BE CASSIE'S
BECAUSE WHO WOULD EAT
LOW CARB BROWNIES?
Cassie: WHICH ARE
$6 A BAG,
WHICH IS VERY EXPENSIVE
FOR A LITTLE THING OF BROWNIES.
Ann: AND THEY WERE SITTING
ON THE COUNTER
WITH ALL OF THE STUFF OUT
THAT SHE USED TO MAKE THEM.
Eva: UGH.
SO IS YOUR OIL FINISHED?
Ann: I WILL NOT COOK
IN A KITCHEN THAT'S DIRTY.
LIKE,
THAT IS DISGUSTING.
Eva: THIS PLACE
IS SO FRUSTRATING.
Ann: IT'S DISGUSTING.
LIKE, WHY IS THIS JUST
LYING HERE?
Eva: UH, YEAH.
Ann: WE SHOULD DRAW
IN IT.
PUT,
"CASSIE, CLEAN YOUR DISHES."
IS THAT RUDE?
Eva: NO,
IT DOESN'T RUIN IT.
Ann: CAN WE JUST
DRAW ON IT?
A LITTLE ART CORNER.
I WROTE WITH A KNIFE
IN HER BROWNIES.
GO!
I'M LIKE, "EVA, YOU CAN BE
THE PATROL PERSON."
BECAUSE WE HAD TO MAKE SURE
NO ONE WAS COMING.
EVA,
I CAN'T FIT "DISHES".
Ann: COME LOOK.
"CLEAN YOUR ..."
Eva: YES. YES.
Ann: I SHOULD'VE WROTE,
"EAT SOME CARBS."
Eva: (laughs)
Ann: I DO HAVE
A SENSE OF HUMOR.
I THOUGHT MAYBE CASSIE
HAD ONE, TOO.
Cassie: IT'S SO MIND-BOGGLING
TO ME
BECAUSE WHO WRITES
IN SOMEONE'S FOOD?
WHO WROTE THAT?
Eva: I DON'T KNOW.
Yaya: SOMEONE HAD
THE AUDACITY TO MUTILATE
HER PRECIOUS
BROWNIES.
Toccara: YOU REALLY PISSED
ABOUT THEM BROWNIES.
Cassie: I AM, BECAUSE WHO
TOUCHES PEOPLE'S FOOD LIKE THAT?
IT'S LIKE ME
STICKING MY HANDS
ALL IN YOUR CHICKEN BREAST
OR SOMETHING.
Ann: (whispers)
SHUT THAT.
Man: What?
Ann: (whispers)
SHUT THE THING.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON,
HOLD ON,
I'M TRYING
TO BE SNEAKY.
Cassie: HEY,
AMANDA.
Kelle: HI, THERE.
Cassie: DID YOU WRITE
IN MY BROWNIES?
Amanda: UNH-UNH.
Cassie: DO YOU KNOW
WHO DID?
Amanda: UNH-UNH.
Cassie: OKAY,
JUST CHECKING.
I QUESTIONED EVERYONE
IN THE HOUSE.
I JUST SAID,
"DID YOU WRITE IN MY BROWNIES?"
Eva: I WOULD TELL YOU
IF I DID, BUT I DIDN'T.
Cassie: OKAY,
THAT'S FINE.
I JUST--
Toccara: WHO DID IT?
Eva: NOT I.
Cassie: EVA WAS LIKE,
"IT WASN'T ME,"
BUT SHE WAS KINDA HINTING THAT
SHE KNEW IT WAS SOMEONE ELSE.
AND WHO ELSE IS UNDER EVA'S BUTT
THE WHOLE TIME, EXCEPT ANN?
Cassie: DID YOU WRITE
IN MY CAKE?
Ann: NO.
Cassie: EVA SAID, "NO."
YOU SAY "NO"
AND AMANDA SAID "NO," SO...
Ann: NOPE.
Cassie: OKAY.
Ann: NO ONE WILL FESS UP
TO THAT.
Yaya: IT WAS ONE
OF THOSE GIRLS.
Cassie: DUH.
Ann: SHE'S
SO PISSED.
Eva: SHE'S MAD,
AND I DON'T CARE.
Yaya: I'M WEARING THIS SHIRT
FOR YOU.
RESPEITO--
IN PORTUGUESE
CAN YOU SAY, "RESPECT"?
LIKE, "FALTA DO RESPEITO."
IN THIS HOUSE
THERE'S NO RESPECT.
Amanda: NO ONE WOULD ADMIT
TO THE "INCIDENT."
THE "BROWNIEGATE '04."
Eva: WOW,
WHAT HAPPENED?
I COULD NOT
HELP LAUGHING.
Norelle:
IT WASN'T ME.
Yaya: (laughs)
Amanda: WE'RE LIKE,
"NOTHING."
Cassie: SOMEONE NEEDS
TO TELL ME
WHO STUCK THEIR DAMN FINGERS
IN MY BROWNIES,
AND THEN THEY NEED
TO BUY ME SOME MORE BROWNIES.
Toccara: SO IF NICOLE
DIDN'T DO IT,
AND AMANDA DIDN'T DO IT,
AND KELLE
DIDN'T DO IT,
AND TOCCARA DIDN'T STEAL
THE COOKIES FROM THE COOKIE JAR,
AND YAYA DIDN'T STEAL THE
COOKIES FROM THE COOKIE JAR...
♪ AND NORELLE DIDN'T STEAL THE
COOKIES FROM THE COOKIE JAR ♪♪
Amanda: YEP, YEP.
Toccara: ♪ AND EVA DIDN'T
STEAL-- ♪
Amanda: MMM!
Toccara: I'LL SEE Y'ALL
AT DINNER.
Kelle: OH, YIKES.
IT'S GONNA BE
SOME DRAMA.
Toccara: SO WE GET
TO THE DINNER,
AND EVERYTHING IS KINDA,
LIKE, FINE.
AND THEN ANN LOOKS OVER
AT YAYA,
AND SHE SAYS,
"WHAT DOES YOUR SHIRT MEAN?"
Ann: YAYA,
WHAT DOES THAT--
Yaya: IT'S RESPEITO.
IN PORTUGUESE,
IT MEANS "RESPECT."
THERE'S A BIG LACK OF IT
IN THE HOUSE,
SO I FELT THE NEED
TO WEAR IT TODAY.
CASSIE'S BROWNIES
WERE FINGERED.
I JUST THINK
IT MEANS THAT
THERE'S IMMATURITY IN RESPECT
IN THE HOUSE.
AND THAT WAS EXEMPT--
Ann: WHY IS IT
IMMATURE?
Yaya: WHY IS IT IMMATURE?
Cassie: WHO WRITES
IN FOOD?
WHO WRITES IN SOMEONE'S
BROWNIES?
Ann: I WAS GONNA SAY
SOMETHING TO YOU ANYWAYS.
I DID THAT TODAY
TO BE FUNNY.
IT WASN'T TO BE--
I DIDN'T DO IT TO HURT YOU
OR 'CAUSE I DON'T LIKE YOU.
OKAY, THAT'S FINE,
IT WAS A JOKE,
I'M SORRY.
I WAS TRYING TO BE FUNNY,
I THOUGHT YOU COULD--
I THOUGHT YOU WOULD THINK
IT WAS FUNNY.
Cassie: IT'S NOT FUNNY.
Yaya: DO YOU HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH CASSIE WHERE YOU THOUGHT
THAT SHE HONESTLY
WOULD THINK IT WAS FUNNY?
MAYBE IF YOU DID IT TO EVA,
YOU'D BE LIKE, "HA HA HA,"
BUT THAT'S
NOT THE CASE.
Ann: OKAY, I GUESS I LOOK
AT IT AS IF, LIKE,
IF ONE OF YOU GUYS
DID THAT TO ME, I'D LAUGH.
Yaya: SOME PEOPLE THINK IT'S
FUNNY TO KILL PEOPLE.
THAT DOESN'T
MAKE IT FUNNY.
Ann: OKAY, WELL, I'M SORRY
THAT YOU'RE SO MATURE
AND THAT YOU HAVE
NO SENSE OF HUMOR.
Cassie: I MEAN, WE DON'T HAVE
TO BE HOSTILE TO EACH OTHER,
BUT DON'T TOUCH MY STUFF
'CAUSE IT'S NOT FUNNY TO ME.
Ann: OKAY, WELL, WHEN YOU
WERE MAKING YOURSELF THROW UP
AND YOU DIDN'T WANT ANYONE
TO TALK ABOUT IT, YOU SAID THAT,
AND WE STOPPED TALKING
ABOUT IT.
Cassie: THAT'S FINE.
Ann: SO STOP TALKING ABOUT
ME, BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE IT.
Cassie: I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT
YOU, I'LL TELL YOU THAT NOW.
Ann: WELL, THEN I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT HOW YOU'RE BULIMIC.
Cassie: THAT'S GREAT.
Ann: I'LL TELL
TYRA TOMORROW.
Cassie: SHE KNOWS,
ACTUALLY.
WE TALKED
ABOUT IT TODAY.
Ann: GOOD.
Eva: LET'S TRY THIS.
HOW ABOUT EVERYONE WASH
THEIR OWN DISHES?
Ann: CLEAN YOUR DISHES.
DON'T BE A PIG--
THAT'S DISGUSTING.
WHO WANTS TO LIVE WITH YOUR
DISHES IN THE SINK FOR A WEEK?
Cassie: WHO WANTS TO LIVE
WITH YOU, ANN?
OKAY, WELL
DON'T TOUCH MY...
I DON'T NEED YOU TO TELL ME
TO WASH MY...
AND I DON'T NEED YOU TO PUT
A KNIFE IN MY BROWNIES
AND WRITE,
"CLEAN YOUR..."
DON'T EVER
TOUCH MY STUFF.
Cassie: I DON'T NEED YOU
TO PUT A KNIFE IN MY BROWNIES
AND WRITE,
"CLEAN YOUR..."
DON'T EVER
TOUCH MY STUFF.
Ann: CASSIE WILL NOT
DO HER DISHES.
SO I WROTE WITH A KNIFE
IN HER BROWNIES.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE, LIKE,
A JOKE.
DID I RUIN IT?
DID I PISS ON IT?
Cassie: IF I STUCK
MY FINGER IN YOUR CAKE
AND WENT LIKE THIS--
Ann: DID I USE
A FINGER?
I USED A KNIFE,
HONEY.
Yaya: THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY
MANY DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF MATURITY AND EXPERIENCE
IN THIS HOUSE.
WHETHER IT COMES TO WHAT KIND
OF SENSE OF HUMOR WE HAVE,
OR HOW OFTEN WE WANNA
WASH OUR DISHES,
WE ARE NOT THE SAME KINDS
OF PEOPLE, BUT RESPECT--
RESPEITO IS THE ISSUE.
MOVING ON,
GROWING UP.
Cassie: I DON'T LIKE A LOT
OF DRAMA COMING FROM GIRLS,
BUT WITH ANN,
THAT'S NOT AVOIDABLE HERE.
Cassie:
I DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY THINK THAT I'M THE ONLY ONE
THAT DOESN'T CLEAN MY DISHES,
BECAUSE THERE'S A PILE
OF DISHES IN THE SINK RIGHT NOW,
AND NONE OF THEM
ARE MINE.
Ann: TYRA MAIL!
Nicole: "DO YOU HAVE WHAT
IT TAKES TO RISE TO THE TOP?
"BE READY TO PROVE IT
AT 10:00."
Women: YAY!
♪♪♪
Toccara: I STEP OUT
THE ELEVATOR, AND I'M LIKE,
"AAH! THIS IS SO GREAT!
I AM SO EXCITED!"
WE GOT THE ROPE COURSE,
THE WALLS, THE TIRES.
OH, MY GOD!
Eva: EVERYBODY'S
JUMPING UP AND DOWN.
"YAY! YAY!"
OKAY,
SO WHY ARE WE EXCITED?
THIS IS
AN OBSTACLE COURSE.
Captain: GOOD MORNING,
LADIES, I'M CAPTAIN
LEIF WADE--
FORMER CAPTAIN
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
YOU ARE
NO LONGER CIVILIANS.
YOU'RE RECRUITS
TO PURE POWER BOOT CAMP.
Eva: BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
(imitates Captain)
TODAY IS ABOUT TENACITY,
STRENGTH, LOYALTY.
Captain: WHEN YOU COME ACROSS
REJECTION IN THE MODELING WORLD,
YOU CANNOT QUIT.
JUST LIKE I WILL NOT LET YOU
QUIT HERE TODAY.
IT'S GONNA BE ONE OF THE HARDEST
WORKOUTS YOU'VE EVER DONE.
("Reveille" playing)
Yaya: I DON'T LIKE
PUTTING ON FATIGUES
AND ACTING LIKE I'M GOING
THROUGH THE JUNGLE
KILLING PEOPLE,
YOU KNOW?
SO I WAS JUST NOT EXCITED
AT ALL.
Ann: I WAS PUMPED AS HELL.
I WORK OUT,
I PLAY WATER POLO.
ACTUAL PHYSICAL ACTIVITY--
I FEED OFF THAT.
Captain: ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
FALL IN.
WATCH YOURSELF,
BE SAFE OUT HERE,
MAXIMUM EFFORT,
THREE... TWO... ONE!
GO!
WATCH YOUR KNEES.
GOOD!
OH, YOU ALL RIGHT?
I GOT YOU.
WATCH YOUR KNEES.
GOOD.
WHOA.
COME ON. KICK THAT!
NICE!
Ann: EVERYTHING I'VE EVER DONE
I'VE BEEN GOOD AT
OR ONE OF
THE BEST PEOPLE,
SPORTS--
WHATEVER.
Yaya: I DO FEEL EXTREME
COMPETITIVE ENERGY FROM ANN.
SHE'S THE TOP ATHLETE,
AND I'M MAYBE SEEN AS ANOTHER
PHYSICAL PERSON BECAUSE I DANCE.
Captain: PULL,
PULL, PULL.
COME ON,
CASSIE, GET UP.
GET UP, CASSIE,
COME ON,
Yaya: CASSIE JUST DIDN'T
WANT TO PARTICIPATE,
AND SO SHE WAS DOING THINGS
KIND OF MINIMALLY.
Captain: CASSIE,
LET'S GO.
COME ON. BE PROUD.
WHAT ARE YOU PROUD
OF HERE TODAY?
Cassie: (sighs)
NOTHING,
BECAUSE IF I WANTED TO GET
IN THE MILITARY,
I WOULD'VE SIGNED UP
FOR THE MILITARY.
Captain: YOU'RE NOT HERE
TO GET IN THE MILITARY.
Eva: CASSIE IS THE BIGGEST PUNK
I HAVE EVER MET.
Cassie: I DON'T WANT
TO DO THIS ANYMORE.
Captain: FLIP OVER.
START DOING
PUSH-UPS.
Amanda: I WANTED THE SERGEANT
TO REALLY JUST DRILL HER
AND YELL AT HER, SAY,
(imitates Captain)
"YOU SUCK, YOU MAGGOT!
"GET UP! AAH!
SHUT UP!"
Cassie:
THIS IS DUMB.
THIS IS
REALLY CHEESY.
I REALLY DON'T WANNA BE HERE
RIGHT NOW.
I WANNA GO HOME.
I WANNA GO BACK TO OKLAHOMA
RIGHT NOW.
Captain:
BALANCE, FOCUS.
Nicole: OH, YEAH!
Eva: I THINK THE POINT
WAS TO TEACH US
TENACITY
AND ENDURANCE
AND WHEN IT SEEMS EXTREMELY
HARD, DON'T GIVE UP.
TOP MODEL!
Captain:
THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
LISTEN UP.
HEY, SOME OF YOU DID
AN AMAZING JOB OUT HERE TODAY,
SOME DIDN'T DO SO WELL,
AND YOU WILL SEE ME AGAIN.
Women: UH-OH.
Toccara: WE LEAVE
THE BOOT CAMP.
Women: BYE!
Toccara: WE DRIVE
TO ANOTHER LOCATION.
Norelle: THERE'S
CAPTAIN WADE AGAIN.
(imitates Captain)
HELLO, LADIES.
Captain:
Women: HELLO, CAPTAIN.
Captain: DIDN'T THINK YOU'D
SEE ME SO SOON?
Women: NO.
Captain: YOUR CHALLENGE
TODAY
IS A RACE TO THE TOP
OF THE STAIRS
IN THIS 14-STORY
HIGH-RISE.
Toccara: WE'RE LIKE...
"ARE YOU KIDDING ME?"
Captain: THE WINNER
WILL BE BASED
ON THE BEST
INDIVIDUAL TIME.
WHOEVER WINS THIS
WILL BE GREATLY REWARDED.
SO BATTLE IT OUT
AMONGST YOURSELVES,
AND WE'LL SEE WHO HAS
WHAT IT TAKES
TO MAKE IT
TO THE TOP.
Cassie: STAIRS SUCK,
AND I HATE 'EM.
Yaya: I JUST LOOKED AT IT
LIKE, "OH, I CAN DO THIS."
Ann: IT WAS REALLY JUST
ME AND YAYA WHO WERE LIKE,
"LET'S, LIKE, DO THIS."
LIKE, YOU KNOW,
I WAS EXCITED.
Eva: SO WE GO UP
THE FLIGHT OF STAIRS ONE BY ONE.
I'M FIRST.
Man: GO!
Ann: GO, EVA!
Ann: GO, KELLE!
Man: GO!
Ann: GO, CASSIE!
GO!
Eva: I'M RUNNING, I'M RUNNING.
I'M RUNNING.
I DON'T HAVE
NO MORE BREATH.
Kelle: UM,
IT'S REALLY HARD,
BECAUSE I'M NOT AN ATHLETE
IN THE SLIGHTEST BIT.
Toccara:
I DID PRETTY GOOD.
I GOT TO THE SEVENTH FLOOR
BEFORE I WAS LIKE, "UGH."
Yaya: EVEN WHEN I WANTED
TO STOP ON THE STAIRWELL,
I DIDN'T.
AND I MIGHT'VE
SLOWED DOWN,
BUT I DIDN'T
JUST STOP.
Ann: I DON'T FAIL
AT THINGS.
I DON'T NOT
FINISH THINGS.
Cassie: I WAS
WHEEZING LIKE...
(wheezes)
I COULD BARELY BREATHE,
YOU KNOW,
'CAUSE I DIDN'T
WANT TO FINISH LAST.
Eva: (panting)
Captain: 1.33.
TOP MODEL NEEDS TO LOOK GOOD
ON A MOMENT'S NOTICE.
YOU NOW HAVE
A PHOTO SHOOT.
Eva: (retches)
YOU HAVE TO BE
KIDDING ME.
I CAN'T
EVEN BREATHE.
(retches)
SO I JUST DECIDED,
"HELL, I'M GONNA SMILE
IN THESE PICTURES."
Captain: GOOD.
YOU HAVE
A PHOTO SHOOT.
Kelle:
A PHOTO SHOOT NOW?
Eva: YEAH.
Yaya: THE REAL CHALLENGE IS
IF I'M ON A PHOTO SHOOT
AFTER NOT HAVING SLEPT,
AFTER NOT HAVING EATEN--
WHOO!
IT'S NOT GOOD!
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE
TO JUST HAVE THAT ENDURANCE.
Captain: GOOD.
YOU NOW HAVE
A PHOTO SHOOT.
Ann: YOU KNOW,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO ME
IS TO HAVE A GOOD PICTURE.
AND I'VE ONLY HAD ONE
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY WERE LIKE,
"THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
WE LIKE IT."
Captain: YOU NOW HAVE
A PHOTO SHOOT.
Amanda: OKAY.
Captain: YOU GOT
A PHOTO SHOOT.
Toccara: NO,
I DON'T.
Captain: OH, YEAH,
COME ON.
Toccara: NO,
I DON'T.
OH, I'M JUST POSING?
Ché: YEAH.
Toccara: I THINK
THAT PHOTO SHOOT SUCKED.
Captain: ON YOUR FEET,
LADIES!
NONE OF YOU QUIT,
ALL RIGHT?
WHICH IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING HERE.
THE TIMES
WERE VERY CLOSE.
IN 9th PLACE
IS KELLE--2.34.
Kelle: I WASN'T REALLY
EXPECTING TO WIN
'CAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY GIRLS
FAR MORE ATHLETIC THAN ME.
Captain: EIGHTH--
NORELLE.
SEVENTH--
TOCCARA.
Ann: GOOD FOR TOCCARA,
BUT, LIKE, HOW DOES NORELLE
AND KELLE FEEL
THAT THEY JUST
LOST TO, YOU KNOW,
A GIRL THAT WEIGHS
50 MORE POUNDS THAN THEM?
Captain: SIXTH--AMANDA.
FIFTH IS CASSIE.
Cassie: I WAS JUST HAPPY
I GOT TO THE TOP
AND DIDN'T FINISH LAST.
Captain: FOURTH
IS NICOLE.
THIRD IS EVA.
Toccara: IT WAS BETWEEN
YAYA AND ANN.
Captain: TODAY'S WINNER...
YAYA.
Yaya: WHOO!
Captain: 1.10.
Yaya: YEAH!
Captain: NOW, YAYA,
YOU GET TO PICK ONE PERSON.
Yaya: I PICK TOCCARA!
Toccara: YEAH!
Captain: ALL RIGHT.
Yaya: TOCCARA WAS ONE
OF THE PEOPLE THAT REALLY
EXEMPLIFIED NOT GIVING UP
AND SURPASSING EXPECTATIONS.
Captain: YOU TWO BEAUTIFUL
LADIES ARE GONNA ENJOY
A WONDERFUL, BEAUTIFUL EVENING
HERE AT CLAY SPA,
UP HERE
ON THIS ROOF DECK.
Toccara: OOH.
Yaya: YAY!
Captain: THE REST OF YOU LADIES
ARE NOT SO LUCKY.
YOU HAVE
TO WALK HOME.
Norelle: AFTER THAT
BRUTAL DAY WE HAD?
Ann: DOES ANYONE EVEN KNOW
WHICH WAY WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GO?
Eva: RIGHT OR LEFT?
Kelle: RIGHT.
Cassie: MAKE A RIGHT.
Cassie: SO YAYA AND TOCCARA
GOT TO STAY
AND DO
THEIR LITTLE FACIALS.
Eva: THE PERSON THAT NEEDED
THE FACIAL, GOT THE FACIAL.
Amanda:
♪ ADVENTURES ♪
♪ WITH A BLIND TOOL ♪♪
AND 20 BLOCKS IN NEW YORK
EQUALS ONE MILE.
Amanda: REALLY?
Kelle: YEAH.
Yaya: I KNOW.
Toccara: JUST
TO BE OUTSIDE.
Yaya: EVERY PANEL
I'VE BEEN CRITICIZED
FOR LETTING MY DANCERISH-NESS
SHINE THROUGH.
Tyra: WHEN I LOOKED
AT THE PICTURE,
I DID NOT SEE
A MODEL.
IT WAS TOO DANCER.
Nigel: IT WAS ALMOST
TOO DRAMATIC.
Yaya: WHAT I'M STRUGGLING WITH
RIGHT NOW IS
HOW TO SET ASIDE
SOMETHING
THAT IS SO MUCH
A PART OF ME, YOU KNOW?
Toccara: RIGHT.
Yaya: YOU KNOW, LIKE,
THE DEFINITION OF "YAYA"--
DANCE IS UP THERE.
Cassie:
I THINK I HAD
THE HOLLYWOOD IMAGE
OF NEW YORK CITY IN MY HEAD.
AND WHEN I CAME HERE,
I WAS SO DISAPPOINTED BY IT.
IT'S HARD TO COME HERE
AND SEE JUST THIS BIG PLACE
WHERE IT'S REALLY DIRTY,
AND IT'S REAL EXPENSIVE.
Kelle: YOU GUYS,
WE'RE GONNA MAKE A LEFT
AT THIS CORNER.
Eva: KELLE
WAS OUR TOUR GUIDE.
WELL, THIS IS ALL CALLED
GREENWICH VILLAGE.
FOLLOW ME, LADIES.
FOLLOW THE HAND.
FINALLY,
SOMETHING I CAN DO.
OH, MY GOD.
(knock on door)
Ann: HELLO.
Cassie: HAPPINESS TO ME
IS JUST THAT FEELING
THAT CAN'T BE DESCRIBED,
AND IT'S NOT HERE
RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T WANNA LIVE
IN NEW YORK CITY
IF I DON'T HAVE THAT FEELING
IN MY HEART, YOU KNOW?
RIGHT NOW
I DON'T HAVE IT.
BEING IN THIS COMPETITION,
NEW YORK IS NOT AS GLAMOROUS
AS I PICTURED IT TO BE,
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
I'M SO DISAPPOINTED.
'CAUSE IT WAS ALWAYS,
LIKE,
MY DREAM CITY THAT I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD GET TO GO TO.
AND NOW I'M HERE,
AND I HATE IT.
I FEEL LIKE ALL MY SPIRIT
IS GONE HERE.
C.J.: Just be
a trooper.
Cassie: I'LL TRY MY BEST.
C.J.: Try my best?
Cassie: WILL YOU BE MAD
IF I COME HOME EARLY?
Kelle: YOU GUYS,
TYRA MAIL!
"LIGHTS, CAMERA, ACTION.
"TOMORROW GET A JUMP START TO
YOUR DAY AND BE READY AT 7:30."
Toccara: OKAY.
Jay: GOOD MORNING.
SO I KNOW YOU GUYS
ARE ALREADY THINKING,
"WHAT THE HECK?"
NOW SOME OF YOU STILL HAVE
ISSUES POSING ON THE GROUND,
BUT TODAY IT'S
EVEN MORE CHALLENGING,
BECAUSE YOU NEED TO LEARN
HOW TO POSE
WHILE IN FLIGHT
IN THE AIR.
Ann: HONESTLY,
MY HEART STOPPED.
I'M DEATHLY AFRAID
OF AIRPLANES.
Jay: SO, OF COURSE,
TO DO THIS SHOOT RIGHT,
I HAD TO GET A PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT'S SHOT TYRA,
AND HIS NAME
IS SASCHA PFLAEGING.
Sascha: IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
DEMANDING PHYSICALLY TODAY.
I HOPE YOU ALL HAVE
A LOT OF ENERGY.
Jay: ALL RIGHT,
LET'S DO IT.
Amanda: WE WERE THINKING THAT
WE WERE GONNA, LIKE,
BUNGEE JUMP
FROM AN AIRPLANE,
LIKE OVER THE WATER,
LAND ON A BOAT WITH, LIKE,
A THING OF YOGURT OR SOMETHING.
WE HAD NO IDEA.
Jay: HEY, DANILO,
MATHU,
CAN I TAKE THOSE GIRLS FROM YOU
FOR JUST A SECOND?
OKAY, THE SHOOT TODAY
IS FOR YJ STINGER.
IT'S AN ENERGY DRINK.
SO THIS IS AN ACTION SHOT TODAY,
ALL RIGHT?
WE HAVE
A BIG TRAMPOLINE.
Amanda: THE TRAMPOLINE
OF DOOM!
Jay: AND YOU HAVE TO LEARN
HOW TO BOUNCE, GIVING ME FACE,
GIVING ME BODY
IN THE AIR, OKAY?
Kelle: I GUESS I DON'T
DEAL WELL WITH, LIKE,
"YEAH,
YOU'RE DOING GREAT,"
'CAUSE I'M NOT REALLY
DOING GREAT.
SO TELL ME, LIKE,
"YOU'RE NOT DOING THIS RIGHT"
AS OPPOSED TO, LIKE,
"YEAH, YOU'RE DOING GREAT"
AND THEN EXPECTING ME
TO DO BETTER.
Jay: BUT, YOU KNOW,
AT THE SAME TIME, KELLE,
I CAN'T BABY YOU
THROUGH EVERY FRAME.
I'M TIRED OF TALKING
ABOUT KELLE.
I'M TIRED
OF TALKING TO KELLE.
OF SEEING KELLE CRY.
Kelle: ACCEPTED THE FACT THAT
I CAN'T TAKE A GOOD PICTURE,
BUT NOW I'M TRYING
TO WORK ON THAT,
AND I KEEP ON WITH IT.
(sniffles)
WHATEVER.
I NEED HELP.
I'VE NEVER
DONE THIS BEFORE.
IF I COULD TAKE PERFECT PHOTOS
AND I KNEW WHAT I WAS DOING,
I'D BE IN AN AGENCY.
Ann: SHE WASN'T SAYING,
"BABY ME ALONG."
ALL SHE WAS SAYING WAS
IF SHE'S DOING BAD,
DON'T TELL HER
SHE'S DOING GOOD.
Sascha: ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GO.
THREE. GOOD.
THREE.
Jay: GOOD FACE.
Sascha: CASSIE--
SHE'S VERY COMFORTABLE
JUMPING UP AND DOWN.
THERE WERE SOME
REALLY NICE MOVES
AND SOME REALLY
BEAUTIFUL SHOTS,
BUT CASSIE DIDN'T HAVE
A LOT OF VARIETY.
Sascha: ONE...
TWO...
THREE. NICE.
Jay: EVA WAS EXCITED,
AND SHE REALLY
GAVE ME ENERGY.
Sascha: SHE'S GOOD.
SHE'S REALLY NICE.
SHE'S PRETTY.
BUT IT'S JUST NOT
A LOT OF RANGE.
Michelle: PERFECT.
Mathu: IT'S A GOOD THING.
Michelle: AND WE ARE
IN AGGREEANCE?
THIS IS HER OUTFIT,
ALL RIGHT?
Sascha: ONE... TWO...
THREE...
FOR BEING A LITTLE BIGGER GIRL,
TOCCARA WAS REALLY GOOD.
THREE.
Nicole: IT'S TRICKY
ON THE TRAMPOLINE.
YOU HAD TO KEEP A LOT OF FACTORS
IN MIND--THE DRESS,
THE PRODUCT
YOU'RE SELLING,
YOUR FACE.
Eva: DO DIFFERENT STUFF
WITH YOUR ARMS.
REMEMBER THAT YOU GOTTA
PRESENT THE CAN.
Sascha: NORELLE IS
A LITTLE BIT SCRAWNY
AND A LITTLE BONY,
BUT FOR HER THIS SITUATION
MADE IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
TO FIND A VERY NICE,
GOOD-LOOKING, ELEGANT POSITION.
Norelle: WHAT'S WRONG
WITH ME?
Kelle: HI.
I'M KELLE.
Sascha: HI KELLE,
NICE TO MEET YOU.
Kelle: I HAD
A REALLY CUTE DRESS
I WAS SO EXCITED
TO WEAR,
THEN I START JUMPING,
AND MY ENTIRE TOP
COMES OUT OF MY DRESS,
Woman: JUST A SEC.
Yaya: DON'T KEEP DOING IT,
PLEASE.
Kelle: THIS IS
THE PROBLEM.
Yaya: LOOK. AAH!
Kelle: AAH!
Sascha: WARDROBE?
Kelle: AND SO MICHELLE HAD
TO TRY TO FIND ANOTHER DRESS.
Michelle: YOU'RE BOUNCING
AROUND IN THERE?
NOTHING'S HAPPENING?
Sascha: THREE...
JUST KEEP
YOUR LEGS UP.
STRAIGHT LOOKING
AT THE LIGHTS.
JUST... YEAH.
AND LOOK
INTO THE LIGHT,
JUST THROW YOUR NECK BACK
A LITTLE BIT.
Jay: KELLE IS JUST
SO SELF-CONSCIOUS
THAT SHE FLUNKS
AS A MODEL
WHEN SHE GETS IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA.
Kelle: I DON'T REALLY HAVE
ANYTHING POSITIVE TO GO ON
AS TO WHY I AM HERE.
I MEAN,
IT'S REALLY HARD,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
IN THE MIRROR AND, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE BREAKING
YOUR FACE APART
AND YOU JUST WONDER,
"HOW CAN I EVER MAKE THIS LOOK
PRETTY ON FILM?"
AND THEN YOU GET HERE,
AND YOU CAN'T.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
Michelle: LET ME SEE,
HONEY.
TURN AROUND.
YEAH, AND THEN
YOU'RE GONNA JUMP.
LIKE,
HOLD IT AND JUMP.
LET'S SEE.
I WANNA MAKE SURE.
OOH!
I KEEP FORGETTING
YOU GIRLS ARE SO TALL.
Ann: I HAVE TO PROVE
THAT I DESERVE TO BE HERE,
BECAUSE I'VE ONLY HAD
ONE GOOD PICTURE
OUT OF ALL THE SHOOTS
WE'VE DONE.
Sascha: ONE... TWO...
THREE.
ANN DIDN'T SEEM TO BE BOTHERED
BY HURTING HERSELF,
SO SHE REALLY GAVE A LOT
INTO IT.
THREE. GOOD.
BEAUTIFUL.
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
Ann: YEAH.
Sascha: LESS IS MORE.
Ann: LESS IS MORE.
OKAY.
Jay: ANN WAS JUST
A BIG FLOP.
LITERALLY,
SHE FLOPPED.
SHE SCRAPED
HER CHIN.
HER ELBOWS.
SHE LOOKS
A MESS.
Ann: I TRIED TO FLY,
AND I DON'T KNOW
IF IT WORKED OR NOT.
Jay: SHE'S GOT THAT FACE,
THAT...
THAT'S ANN.
Ann: OW.
IS IT BLEEDING?
Man: A LITTLE BIT.
Danilo: SHAPE--
PROBABLY WANT A LITTLE TIGHTER
RIGHT THERE.
Yaya: ACCORDING TO
SOME OF THE PANELISTS,
MY PHOTOS LOOK
LIKE A DANCER.
AND SOME OF THEM I LIKED
THAT THE PANEL DIDN'T LIKE.
Danilo: YEAH.
Yaya: ON SOME OF THEM,
THE PANEL LIKED
AND I DIDN'T LIKE.
Danilo: GOD BLESS
THE PANEL.
Yaya: ANY INSTINCTUAL POSES
THAT I WOULD DO
MIGHT HAVE TRACES
OF "DANCERATION" IN IT,
SO I TRIED
TO STRIP THAT AWAY,
AND I THINK IT ENDED UP MAKING
MY SHOOT A LITTLE BIT BORING.
Sascha: THREE.
Jay: YAYA TOOK HER ADVICE
FROM THE PANEL
AND TOOK IT
TO THE EXTREME,
WHICH, IN THAT CASE,
ISN'T HELPING HER.
Sascha: AMANDA
WAS BEAUTIFUL.
SHE HAD IT ALL.
SHE SHOWED
A LOT OF VARIETY,
AND SHE WORKED
WITH HER BODY.
Eva: SHE'S KICKING ASS.
Mathu: SHE IS KICKING
MAJOR ASS.
Yaya: AMANDA,
GO HOME.
Eva: AMANDA WAS DOING
DANCER-LIKE POSES,
AND YAYA WAS GETTING PISSY
OVER THERE.
Yaya: OKAY.
SO FUNNY.
THIS IS JUST FUNNY.
THIS IS FUNNY.
Eva: "IT'S NOT FAIR.
"THEY TOLD ME I CAN'T DO
DANCER POSES,
"AND WATCH, THEY'LL LOVE
AMANDA'S POSES."
Jay: COME HERE
FOR A SECOND, PLEASE.
I JUST WANT YOU
TO UNDERSTAND,
LIKE, YOU SUPER
IMPRESSED ME.
I DIDN'T SAY A WORD.
IN MY OPINION,
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE
WHO GOT THIS TODAY,
AND I HAVEN'T COMMENTED
ON ANYONE TODAY.
Amanda: THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THAT MEANS A LOT.
Yaya: I'M REALLY MAD
THAT I DIDN'T DO
WHAT I WANTED TO--
YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING?
Eva: YAYA GOES,
"WELL,
THEY TOLD ME I CAN'T DO
DANCER-LIKE POSES,"
SO THERE'S ALWAYS AN EXCUSE
FOR EVERYTHING.
CAN IT BE BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT PERFECT?
NO. MISS YAYA
DOESN'T THINK SO.
Yaya: AFTERWARD,
I DID SOME COOL STUFF,
AND JAY WAS LIKE, "WHY DIDN'T
YOU DO THAT UP THERE?"
EVERY WEEK I GET
THE SAME COMMENT, LIKE,
"THERE GOES
THAT DANCER THING."
Jay: YOU SHOULDN'T
TAKE EVERYTHING
AS A HARD-AND-FAST RULE,
'CAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
IN THIS WORLD, TEN PEOPLE ARE
GONNA SAY, "DON'T DO THIS.
"DON'T DO THIS.
DON'T DO THIS.
"DON'T DO THIS."
YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA END UP WITH?
NOTHIN' TO DO.
Yaya: HMM.
Cassie: TYRA MAIL.
Eva: TYRA MAIL!
Cassie: "TOMORROW YOU MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY EIGHT OF YOU WILL
CONTINUE ON IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Ann: IT'S GETTING DOWN
TO THE WIRE THAT THERE ARE
ENOUGH PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
CONSISTENTLY GOOD
THAT YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE
A BAD WEEK HERE,
SO I WILL BE NERVOUS.
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
Women: HELLO.
Tyra: THIS WEEK,
YOU LEARNED ALL ABOUT FITNESS
AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF BEING MOTIVATED
AND WANTING IT.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR SIXTH CUT
TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE
SOME AMAZING PRIZES--
A MODEL CONTRACT WITH THE TOP
INTERNATIONAL MODELING AGENCY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
WITH WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMONE,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
Janice: WOW.
Tyra: AND OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE SOME JUDGES.
FIRST IS
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS THE VERY FIRST
SUPERMODEL
EVER TO EXIST
ON THIS PLANET.
WE ALSO HAVE NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
NOLE MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
Nolé: HOW ARE YOU,
LADIES?
MINI SAYS HI.
Women: HEY!
Tyra: AND OUR GUEST JUDGE
FOR THIS WEEK IS KATE DILLON,
WHO IS A FELLOW
TOP MODEL HERSELF.
Kate: HI, YOU GUYS.
YOU GUYS
LOOK AMAZING.
Tyra: WHAT MAKES A TOP MODEL
IS HER ABILITY TO BE ON POINT
NO MATTER HOW TIRED OR EXHAUSTED
SHE IS.
SO WE HAD A PHOTOGRAPHER
STANDING BY TO TAKE YOUR PICTURE
AFTER YOU RAN UP
14 FLIGHTS OF STAIRS.
Woman: OH, NO!
Tyra: THAT DAY
YOU WERE GETTING PHOTOGRAPHED
IS YOUR TEST TODAY.
Women: OHH!
Tyra: YOU WILL ALSO BE TESTED
ON YOUR PHOTO
THAT YOU TOOK
ON A TRAMPOLINE FOR YJ STINGER.
WE HAVE RANDOMLY
DRAWN NAMES,
AND, NORELLE,
YOU'RE FIRST.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY,
NORELLE,
SO HERE IS YOUR EXHAUSTED
PHOTO SHOOT.
Janice: WOW.
SHE DOESN'T
LOOK EXHAUSTED.
SHE LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S IN PAIN.
Nolé: I ACTUALLY
LIKE IT.
I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY MODERN,
KIND OF GRUNGY-LOOKING.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, NORELLE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO JUMP
ON A TRAMPOLINE,
AND LET'S SEE
HOW YOU DID.
Janice: LOVELY.
Nolé: OH, NORELLE,
AMAZING.
Janice: VERY LOVELY.
Kate: YOUR FACE LOOKS
VERY RELAXED,
WHICH I THINK
IS VERY DIFFICULT
WHEN YOU'RE TENSING
YOUR MUSCLES AND JUMPING.
I'M VERY
IMPRESSED.
Norelle:
THANK YOU.
Tyra: KELLE.
Janice: IT'S REALLY BAD,
I'M SORRY.
I CAN'T EVEN
LOOK AT IT.
IT'S THAT BAD.
Nigel: LOOKING AT YOU,
YOU'VE GOT
A GREAT BODY.
IN THIS PICTURE HERE,
THOSE LEGS ACTUALLY LOOK BIG,
YOUR STOMACH
LOOKS BIG.
Janice: YOUR GUT'S
HANGING OUT, YOU KNOW...
Tyra: "A" FOR EFFORT,
BUT "F" FOR THE END PRODUCT.
Nigel:
TOO CONTRIVED.
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IT
ALL TOO MUCH.
Janice: WE'VE NEVER SEEN
EXPRESSION IN YOUR FACE.
IT'S ALWAYS
THE SAME THING.
Nolé: KELLE, WHAT DID YOU DO
BEFORE YOU CAME HERE?
WHAT WAS
YOUR LIFE ABOUT?
Kelle: UM, I ACTUALLY OWN
AN ART GALLERY.
Janice: HAVE YOU HEARD
OF EXPRESSIONISM?
HERE.
Kelle: YEAH.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE NICOLE.
Janice: YOU DON'T REALLY LOOK
LIKE A MODEL IN THIS PICTURE.
Nolé: EVERY TIME
A CAMERA'S ON YOU,
YOU SHOULD
ALWAYS TRY TO STRIKE A POSE,
'CAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW.
Tyra: YES.
Nolé: I MEAN,
I'M WITH THIS GIRL A LOT,AND
SHE'S-- HELLO.
Tyra: EVEN WHEN WE DO
SNAPSHOTS-- YEAH, I'M TIRED.
I WAKE UP,
WHEN I SEE A CAMERA.
Nolé: SHE SNAPS IT UP,
LIKE, AMAZING.
Nigel: WHOA. OOH. GOOD.
Janice: WOW.
THAT'S FIERCE.
Nigel: WHOA!
Nolé: FIERCE.
Tyra: YOU KNOW WHAT
I LIKE ABOUT IT?
THAT IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
SOME OF THE GIRLS.
THEY HELD IT LIKE...
(breathy voice)
"HEY! YJ STINGER."
(normal voice) YOU KNOW,
AND THAT'S NOT FASHION.
THIS IS FASHION.
UP NEXT
WE HAVE TOCCARA.
LOOK AT THAT.
THE INTENSITY
WITH NO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
Nigel: YEAH.
Tyra: SO YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT ON A TRAMPOLINE.
Nolé: YOU LOOK KINDA LIKE
A RAGING BULL--FLARING NOSTRILS.
I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THIS.
Kate: YOU HAVE WHAT
A LOT OF PLUS-SIZED MODELS HAVE,
WHICH IS A SENSE OF FREEDOM
IN THEIR BODY,
AND THAT KIND OF ENERGY
OBVIOUSLY REALLY SHOWS THROUGH.
Tyra: CASSIE.
Kate: I THINK THE POSES
ARE A LITTLE TOO MODEL-Y.
A LITTLE TOO, LIKE...
Tyra: HERE'S
YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: HELP ME.
Nigel: (laughing)
Tyra: I LIKE IT.
Cassie: WHOA,
I LOOK SCARY.
Janice: YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU BELONG IN A CORNFIELD,
LIKE SCARING CROWS AWAY.
(imitates crow cawing)
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
SAID
THAT "CASSIE LOOKS TIRED
AND WEAK
AND NOT SURE
IF SHE REALLY WANTS TO BE HERE."
Janice: WHAT'S UP
WITH THAT?
Cassie: I DON'T KNOW.
Tyra: EVA.
WELL, HOW DID YOU FEEL?
Eva: TIRED.
I GAGGED.
I WAS ONE OF THE FEW GIRLS
THAT GAGGED.
Nigel: THE FACT THAT YOU WERE
ABOUT TO BE SICK--
I MEAN, THIS IS
PRETTY PULLED TOGETHER.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
Janice: YOU LOOK 5'11"
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
Kate: YOU DO LOOK 5'11".
Janice:
MISS SHORTY GIRL.
Tyra: CAN WE SEE
A CLOSEUP?
Janice: YOU CAN'T SEE THE FLARED
NOSTRIL THINGIE ANYMORE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO BRING
YOUR HEAD DOWN A LITTLE
AND KIND OF KEEP THE NOSE
TOGETHER.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY,
AMANDA,
HERE ARE
YOUR THREE SHOTS.
Janice: NOT BAD.
Kate: NOT BAD
AT ALL.
Nolé: GORGEOUS,
ACTUALLY.
Kate: NOT BAD AT ALL
Nolé: BEAUTIFUL.
Nigel: ONE OF THE MOST
STARTLING THINGS ABOUT THIS
IS NORMALLY WHAT MAKES YOUR
PICTURES GREAT ARE YOUR EYES,
AND YOU REALLY CAN'T SEE THEM
IN ANY OF THE PICTURES,
AND YOU STILL
LOOK GOOD.
Janice: GORGEOUS.
YOU'VE GOT A CLASSIC,
TIMELESS LOOK HERE.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
COMMENTS WERE
THAT YOU WERE
THE SUPERSTAR OF THE SHOOT.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE YAYA.
SO YOU WON THE RACE,
AND HERE ARE
YOUR THREE PICTURES FROM IT.
Nigel: IT'S VERY SPORTS PERSON
KIND OF PHOTOGRAPHS,
BUT THAT'S NICE.
Tyra: THEY'RE NOT BAD.
Janice: BEAUTIFUL,
THAT'S AWESOME.
NO, IT'S NOT WORKING.
Yaya: THIS PHOTO SHOOT WAS
SUCH AN EXPERIMENT FOR ME.
I WENT INTO IT
THINKING,
"DON'T DO ANYTHING DANCE-Y
AT ALL,"
AND I WAS MAD
AT MYSELF FOR A MOMENT.
Tyra: AND YOU SHOULD HAVE
BEEN MAD AT YOURSELF.
YOURS WERE THE WORST
OUT OF THE LOT.
THERE'S AN ART
TO TAKING ADVICE.
WHEN SOMEONE TELLS YOU,
"DON'T LOOK LIKE A DANCER,"
IT MEANS LESS CIRQUE DU SOLEIL,
MORE COUTURE, YOU UNDERSTAND?
SO WHAT YOU DID IS YOU THREW
EVERYTHING OUT THE WINDOW.
Nigel: YOU WANNA TAKE
YOUR STRENGTH AS AN ATHLETE
OR YOUR STRENGTH
AS A DANCER
AND YOUR ELOQUENCE AND THEN
TRANSLATE INTO FASHION.
Yaya: IT'S--IT'S HARD
FINDING THAT BALANCE, YOU KNOW?
YEAH. UM...
Janice: I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
IN THE PICTURES.
THAT WAS GOOD.
Yaya: BUT, UM,
YEAH, IT'S DEEP.
I'M GONNA FIND
THE BALANCE.
Tyra: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT PICTURE?
Yaya: OH,
I DON'T LIKE IT.
Tyra: I DON'T
LIKE IT EITHER.
YAYA, THANKS.
Yaya: THANK YOU.
Tyra: LAST,
WE HAVE ANN.
YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO HIKE
14 FLIGHTS OF STAIRS,
AND HERE ARE
YOUR THREE SHOTS.
SOMEBODY'S TIRED.
Janice: AH,
IT'S PEDESTRIAN.
Tyra: YOUR MOUTH
IS A LITTLE OPEN.
Nolé: JUST DON'T KNOW
WHO YOU ARE AS A MODEL.
YOU'RE NOT
GETTING IT.
Tyra: HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: OKAY,
THAT SCARES ME, TOO.
Nigel: I DON'T LIKE
THIS VERY MUCH.
Nolé: ANN, I MEAN,
YOU'RE SO GORGEOUS,
BUT IT'S NOT COMING ACROSS
IN THESE PHOTOS AT ALL.
Janice: YOU WERE
WORKING HERE,
PHOTOGRAPH
IS NOT WORKING,
AND THERE'S NO "IFs," "ANDs"
OR "BUTs" ABOUT IT.
IT SUCKS. SORRY.
Tyra: YAYA.
Janice: I HOPE
SHE DOESN'T LOSE
HER DANCE TRAINING
TOO MUCH.
Nigel: IT'S ABOUT
MODERATION,
KNOW WHEN TO TURN IT ON,
WHEN IT TURN IT OFF.
Tyra: AMANDA.
GOING THROUGH THE FILM,
I WAS LIKE, "WHOA!"
THIS LOOKS LIKE THE PICTURES
OF GIRLS THAT I WORK WITH.
NICOLE.
Nolé: I HAVE NOT BEEN
A BIG FAN OF NICOLE AT ALL,
BUT IN THIS IMAGE,
SHE SLAMS IT.
Janice: NEVER GIVE UP
ON TOP MODEL.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Nigel: NORELLE REALLY DID
A GOOD JOB IN THIS PICTURE.
Janice: NORELLE IS IN.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Nolé: I'M ALWAYS GONNA BE
ON HER SIDE.
Janice: 'CAUSE YOU'RE
A PLUS-SIZED GIRL, HONEY.
Nolé: THAT'S RIGHT, HONEY,
AND PROUD OF IT.
Nigel: TOCCARA PHOTOGRAPHS
INCREDIBLY WELL NORMALLY.
THIS IS JUST NOT
HER GENRE.
Tyra: EVA.
Nolé: I ABSOLUTELY
ADORE EVA.
Nigel: I THINK SHE HAS
A LOT GOING FOR HER.
Kate: EVA'S IN.
Tyra: ANN.
Kate: I DON'T THINK
ANN IS PHOTOGENIC,
AND IT'S SUCH
A DISAPPOINTMENT.
Tyra: I THINK
ANN IS PHOTOGENIC.
SHE JUST DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT THE HELL TO DO
WITH HER FACE
OR HER BODY.
I FEEL LIKE HER AND KELLE
ARE NECK AND NECK--
PRETTY GIRLS,
DON'T KNOW HOW TO MODEL.
KELLE.
Nigel: WHATEVER SHE DOES,
SHE OVERTHINKS IT
AND SORT
OF SCREWS IT UP.
Kate: I THINK
SHE SEES IT
LIKE THE WAY I CAN LOOK
AT PICASSO
AND SAY, "THAT'S
A GREAT PIECE OF ARTWORK,"
BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO DO THAT.
Nigel: I THINK SHE DOES HAVE
A PRETTY FACE,
AND SHE'S
CERTAINLY LOVELY IN PERSON.
Janice: I THINK SHE SHOULD
GO BACK TO HER ART GALLERY
AND SELL ART
FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE.
Tyra: CASSIE.
Janice: CASSIE DOESN'T HAVE
A CLUE OF WHAT A MODEL IS ABOUT,
AND THIS PHOTOGRAPH
PROVES IT.
Nigel: HER FACE LOOKS
SORT OF ALMOST DEAD.
I'M VERY SURPRISED.
SHE'S A REALLY
PRETTY, PRETTY GIRL.
Kate: IF CASSIE HAD
MORE LIFE BEHIND HER EYES,
I MIGHT SEE MORE
OF HER BEAUTY.
Janice: SHE'S
JUST BLECCH.
Tyra: NINE BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE EIGHT PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE EIGHT OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
EVA.
THIS PICTURE IS
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
Eva: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
AMANDA.
NICOLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YAYA.
YAYA, YOU KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT I'M GONNA SAY TO YOU.
IT'S ALL ABOUT BALANCE
AND TAKING CRITIQUE
AND TAKING IT ALL IN
AND THEN DOING
THE SUM OF THAT
AND COMING UP WITH WHAT
WORKS FOR YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
Yaya: THANK YOU.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
NORELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
Tyra: THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
IS CASSIE.
CASSIE,
YOU LOOK AMAZING.
YOU LOOK LIKE
A REAL MODEL.
I NOTICE A CERTAIN SADNESS
WITH YOU.
I THINK MAYBE TALKING
TO SOMEONE,
YOU COULD KINDA
GET THAT OUT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Cassie: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL ANN AND KELLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: I ONLY HAVE
ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL
THAT WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY
CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL'S NAME
I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR APARTMENT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
I'VE NEVER HAD
TO DO THIS BEFORE,
BUT I'M GIVING BOTH OF YOU
THE EXACT SAME CRITIQUE.
BOTH OF YOU, ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS TO THE EYE.
BUT IT DOESN'T TRANSLATE
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS.
YOU ALL ARE
THE WALKING SIGNPOST FOR
"PRETTY GIRL,
NOT PHOTOGENIC,"
BUT THE JUDGES FEEL
THAT ONE OF YOU MAY HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE POTENTIAL
THAN THE OTHER.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS,
ANN.
YOU ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
Ann: THANK YOU.
Tyra: THANKS, KELLE.
Kelle: THANK YOU.
Toccara: MISS KELLE,
GIVE ME A HUG.
Kelle: I WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO KEEP TRYING,
YET ON THE SAME HAND,
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH
HUMILIATION I CAN TAKE.
MAYBE I'M NOT GOOD
AT THIS,
AND THIS IS WHAT
I'M SUPPOSED TO DO.
YOU KNOW, NOT EVERYONE'S MEANT
TO MODEL.
I'VE HIT
ROCK BOTTOM,
AND I'VE BEEN CALLED
SOME REALLY BAD THINGS,
AND I'VE GROWN
FROM IT.
YOU KNOW,
I GUESS THEY SAY,
LIKE, WHAT DOESN'T KILL YOU
MAKES YOU STRONGER.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
Tyra: HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
THE GIRLS GET
THEIR PARTY ON.
Amanda: WE ALL JUMP
IN THE HOT TUB.
IT JUST BRINGS OUT
YOUR BAD SIDE.
Diane: JUST WEAR THE DRESS
AND LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: FROM
DIANE VON FURSTENBERG
TO CYNTHIA ROWLEY,
THE GIRLS MEET SOME
OF NEW YORK'S TOP DESIGNERS.
Woman: DO YOU THINK
THAT I'M GONNA BE ABLE
TO GET A RACK LIKE THIS
IN YOUR SIZE?
Tyra: BUT IS HIGH FASHION
READY FOR PLUS-SIZED TOCCARA?
Toccara:
(screams) MY BACK!